Speaker 1: So there's one more debate I want to
look at. I wanted to look at the Kerry Lake CNN
interview. I promised I would I just am not
going to have time today, so we'll pick that
up tomorrow. It's less time sensitive. One other
important debate that took place over the weekend
was the one for the Wisconsin Senate race wherein
the incumbent Republican, Ron Johnson, is facing a
very, very strong challenge from a former guest on
this program, Mandela Barnes. And the debate was
very interesting in that Ron Johnson performed so
poorly and so misread the room and missed the mark
that he was booed and he was laughed at multiple
times during the debate. Here is a first segment
in which the crowd just laughs when Ron Johnson
says, and remember, this is this is Wisconsin.
Okay? Ron Johnson not a border state in the sense
that we think about with the US-Mexico border.
The crowd laughs when Johnson says It costs
us more money not to build that crazy,
overpriced wall. It's also funny because Trump
is claiming he did build it, so they're totally
incoherent on this. Listen to the crowd.
Speaker 4: Better than you do have a
chance here. But it is costing us more not to
complete the wall that we already contracted
for and the actually building. All right.
Democrats have voted against three of my
amendments in committee and on the floor. All
but Senator Manchin voted against completing
the wall that we'd already bought and paid for.
Speaker 1: Okay. So it's not true that we had
paid for it, you know, allocating money, which,
by the way, was done incorrectly by Donald Trump,
appropriating funds. You're not allowed
to appropriate for such a project,
but it hadn't been paid for and the crowd
correctly laughing at that very stupid idea.
Another moment where you heard audible laughter
was when Ron Johnson claims the FBI set him up
by giving him some kind of fake briefing. I mean,
it's just conspiracy theory after conspiracy
theory. And again, the crowd seems to recognize
it and just straight up laughing at this guy.
Speaker 4: The Ukrainian people, what we want.
We want what we want. They're defending their
children, their freedom. I think it is good
for us freedom of peoples to hang together
and provide them with defensive weaponry so
they can defend their territory. But again,
I want a full accounting. And in response to
the wild charge of Lieutenant Governor Barnes,
the FBI set me up with a corrupt with a corrupt
briefing and then leave that to smear me.
Speaker 1: I not. It sounds
like a bad comedy show. Sorry.
Speaker 4: I'm sorry. But I hope he is referring
to corruption with the FBI, which I've been
trying to uncover and expose. All right. Yeah.
Speaker 1: I mean, you almost can't help but laugh
other than the fact that this guy is winning. But
we'll get to that in a moment. Here was one moment
where you just take it and you do it the right
way. This is the moment at the end of many debates
when the moderators say, you know, politics can
be so divisive. What's something you admire about
your opponent? And it happened during the Hillary
Trump debates in 2016. And I don't remember what
Trump said, but I think he held it together more
than than Ron Johnson. Ron Johnson couldn't even
just say something positive. Take a look at
this and the crowd reacting very negatively.
Speaker 6: All right. We are down to one final
question here. And both of you have said a lot
tonight about each other now. When we traveled
around the state talking with voters, we heard
repeatedly from people tired of divisive politics
and attack ads. So our final question here tonight
is both of you have been successful in life. You
have 30 seconds here. Mr. Barns, you go first.
What do you find admirable about your opponent?
Speaker 4: Well, no, no. I do think,
you know, the senator is proven to.
Speaker 2: Be a family man. And I think
that's admirable. You know, that's absolutely to
be respected. He speaks about his family. He's
done a lot to provide for them. I absolutely.
Speaker 4: Respect that.
Speaker 1: Mr. Trump. Okay. See how that
was not that was unqualified. He just said,
here's a good thing. Listen to Ron Johnson.
And the crowd just does not like it.
Speaker 4: I mean, likewise, I appreciate the
fact that Lieutenant Governor Barnes had a loving
parents, a schoolteacher, father worked three
shifts. He had a good upbringing. I guess what
puzzles me about that is with that upbringing,
why is he turned against America? I mean,
why why does he find America often? Somehow we had
policies. We did not. I said we said something.
Speaker 1: Admirable, a total lack of class and
disgusting. And then later, when Ron Johnson was
interviewed on Fox News about the fact that
the crowd completely turned against him,
he just claimed the crowd was a setup.
Speaker 4: Debate on Thursday,
said pieces of it. And when you said you were
set up by the FBI, the crowd laughed. Who was
in that crowd? And had they been following
the news? Do you want to put that in context?
Well, I think very. They let in bunch of college
students that were supposed to both get 50.
Audience members and the crowd was much larger
than that. So my guess they're college students.
Let's face it, our colleges, they aren't exactly
teaching history. They're really not talking
about, you know, the relevant, by the way.
Speaker 1: Attacking young voters as well.
Speaker 4: Things that students really ought to
learn in college. They're they're being taught
leftist propaganda, unfortunately. Yeah.
Speaker 1: So one of the worst debate
performances of this entire election cycle, how
is the election actually looking? Well, the bad
news is that Johnson is winning. The good news
is that despite the power of incumbency, Johnson
is winning by only 2.8 points on average, and the
newest polling is 8 to 14 days old. Let's see in a
few more days whether this moves. There is very
limited time left until that election, but we
are tracking it closely. It would be amazing for
Mandela Barnes to be able to defeat Ron Johnson.